дякую дякую Друзі Ну що йдемо на Рекорд
90 хвилин виступу в Верховній Раді
України ще ніколи друзі не було Час
прийшов І зараз це відбудеться дуже
приємно що я можу розраховувати на нашу
президію пан Корнієнко сказав що в разі
необхідності буде надасть Мені він в
тому
числі powerbank а це дійсно потрібно бо
друзі Хочу повідомити вам що я безумовно
зараз це стрімлю щоб ви знали що коли ви
зараз почнете розходитись з роботи щоб
ви знали що це побачать люди бо зараз
іде стрім в tiktok щоби люди побачили як
працює Верховна Рада України бачу от
колеги вже рукою машуть можете помахати
рукою люди вас бачать люди вас дивляться
це важливо люди мають знати як працює
Верховна Рада України тож я до речі
пообіцяв людям що буду в тому числі
поставлю їхні питання до депутатів бо ви
знаєте ви тут позакривалися повністю від
людей преси вже нема ложа преси
пуста не пускаєте гостей пускаєте тільки
Ну коли приїжджають закордонні лідери ми
тут в ролі Хора веірьовки їм співаємо
аматорського не дуже вдало та власне і
все все інше ні Шановний пане Галушко В
мене прохання до вас ви теж великий і і
гарний безумовно але ви закриваєте А
мені хотілося би бачити І щоб люди
бачили бо це є важливо і так ми говоримо
з вами про надзвичайно важливу тему ми з
вами говоримо фактично про державний
бюджет України бо це зміни в Бюджетний
кодекс це зміни яким чином цей бюджет
буде формуватися і яким чином цей бюджет
Буде витрачатися в нашій державі і я
хочу сказати має бути тільки один
пріоритет сьогодні в державі тільки один
Як має виглядати державний бюджет
бюджетний кодекс от все це він має
виглядати дуже просто
армія
крапка соціалка щоб люди вижили крапка
все все більше нічого ми маємо сьогодні
саме таким чином формувати армія
соціалка Все ніяких як нам кажуть да
бруківки серіали і все інше Тільки ви
знаєте якось дивно виходить вчора
президент ступає каже не має бути ніякої
дурнівця на армію а здається колеги тут
його не чують бо в суботу крім нашого
довгого засідання було ще засідання
бюджетного комітету Верховної Ради
України і на цьому бюджетному
комітеті знов повернули гроші на серіали
600 млн грн тепер це взагалі
по-блюзнірськи назвали це програма
підтримки
кінематографії і документування воєнних
злочинів друзі який зв'язок який зв'язок
між цими двома речами який зв'язок між
документуванням воєнних злочинів і
серіалами і іншой дурньой на які ви
хочете витрачати гроші майже 600 млн
грвень друзі це колосальні кошти 600
мльн гривень і їх треба витрачати туди
насправді де вони реально потрібні а де
вони потрібні я ставив на бюджетному
комітеті цю правку зняти 00 млн грнь
серіалов і віддати 600 млн грнь на армію
зняти 2 млрд грн з національного
телемарафону що це за марафон ми будемо
перемагати національним
телемарафоном 2 млрд грвень і віддати на
армію зняти гроші з бруківок і віддати
на армію зняти гроші з різної іншої
дурні і віддати на збройні сили України
на Національну гвардію на державну
прикордонну службу України на СБУ на
державну спеціальну службу транспорту на
гур на всі інші відомства які сьогодні
реально боронять Україну а не на словах
і це роблять реально тому забирайте
гроші зі слів А давайте куди треба Куди
ще треба А ще треба друзі дати кошти на
допомогу дитині в нас сьогодні виплата
на народження дитини
при народженні дитині і далі щомісячна
виплата до трьохрічного віку 860 грн
грн ще раз на дитину на
місяць я розумію дивіться я зараз хочу
показати колегам не дуже це цікаво от
знову ходять щось говорять хтось
сміється комусь смішно Ну от тут
константа прийшла все інше от зараз от
от відбувається А друзі А це все дуже
серйозно надзвичайно серйозно 860 грн як
жити людині як дитині як дитину
виховувати на 860 грн Як Ніяк нема
неможливо А в нас сьогодні такі цифри в
нас сьогодні доплата інваліду самотньому
інваліду на догляд
50 грн на місяць ще раз 50 5:0 папірець
м може ви не розумієте
50 скажіть мені що можна зробити на 50
грн на місяць ну назвіть мені
що в нас сьогодні людина в армії
військовий виведений поза штат отримує
700 800 грн на місяць
ще раз на
місяць
700800 грн на місяць Скажіть мені будь
ласка як як може жити людина на 700-800
грн на місяць Так це ж не просто людина
це воїн який віддав чого людина
потрапляє поза штат не тому що вона
провинилась не тому що вона не хоче
воювати а тому що вона втратила здоров'я
або внаслідок поранення або внаслідок
травми або внаслідок хвороби людину далі
виводять поза штат 700-800 грн на місяць
як жити Ну як за це можна прожити Хто
тут готовий зробити експеримент на собі
і прожити до 700 грн на місяць а ми
слава Богу тут більш-менш
здорові а не так як багато тих хто
сьогодні поза штатом і як вони живуть і
що з ними відбувається і цієї розмови Ми
не маємо і цього тут немає черговий раз
цього немає в бюджеті цього немає в
бюджетному Кодексі ціла низка правок які
я давав які передбачали дати кошти армії
дати кошти на виплати дати кошти на
обмежено придатних дати ко вони не
враховані і вони нікому не цікаві ніхто
не хоче про це чути ніхто не хоче знаєте
закрили очі і все і значить будемо
робити вигляд що Так воно і треба ні
друзі так не має бути так абсолютно не
має бути і я вам це хочу сказати
підвищення соціальних от я хочу від
людей питання щоб ви почули питання
виплати соціальної інвалідам перша друга
група От я зараз читаю вам питання які
від людей шановні народні депутати ну
послухайте Ви може багато вже часу людей
не бачили Я хочу вам сказати 2100 грн
інваліди першої другої групи першої
другої третьої групи 2100 грн Як на них
прожити Ну скажіть ну давайте
відповідати на питання Я все Я розумію
що в державі складний час економіка
зруйнована ворог розумію що ми не можемо
дати всім все розумію що ми не можемо
вирішити всі питання ну але як може бути
одночасно 860 грн на дитину в місяць і
600 млн грвень на
серіали ну на це ж ми знаходимо
кошти як може бути 700 грн пораненому
виведеному поза
штат і млн грнь на серіали і 2 млрд грн
на на національний
телемарафон як може бути зарплата
військовослужбовця в 700
грн в
700 А зарплата прокурора спеціалізованої
антикорупційної прокуратури в 140 000
грн 140 000 грн а суддів Верховного Суду
в 300 000
грн в 300 000 грн
та Як таке може бути Ну де якась
справедливість Я взагалі вважаю що в
країні Да я розумію що тим хто бореться
з корупцією якщо б ми бачили реальну
боротьбу з корупцією треба платити
хороші гроші бо ці люди не можуть жити
за 1000 грнь і боротися з мільярдними
зловживаннями це правда але тоді
по-перше все-таки має бути якась межа і
як таку межу Я пропоную Верховній Раді
скільки сьогодні яка сьогодні
найстрашніша робота в державі і
найважливіша яка
це робота військового на
нуле і військовий на нуле сьогодні
отримує Ну давайте візьмемо доплата за
повний місяць хоча далеко не всім там
доплачують за повний місяць вираховують
кидають артилерістів ракетників і так
далі але давайте уявимо собі 100 000 грн
сплатили чесно повну доплату далі плюс
201 грн це не базова
ставка плюс
за вислугу і за звання ще пару тисяч
грнь залежності візьмемо що це 125 000
грн це максимум який сьогодні отримує
людина яка кожен день кожен день ризикує
своїм життям кожен кожну секунду за
державу за нас з вами за дітей
народжених і ще ненароджених Так давай
чесно скажемо це 125 000 грн це і має
бути от межа 125 000 грвен межа не може
бути в державі зарплата більша за воїна
який кожну секунду ризикує своїм життям
оце
Максимум і не може бути більше 125 000
грвен ні в кого ні в менеджера
Укрнафти ні в судді ні в
прокурора Ні ще в когось ні в радника
офіса президента ні ще в когось 125 000
грн максимум потолок давайте це скажемо
давайте це зробимо і оце люди зрозуміють
але далі в мене питання А де ж результат
на ці ну от Вони отримують суддя 300
прокурор 140 000 грн ми бачили весілля
Це де там на Львівщині де шейхи плакали
коли бачили бо вони собі таке дозволити
не
можуть а А де результат за ці кошти де
результат за ці гроші де подолана
корупція де коли виходе найбільше
Світове видання журнал Тайм і говорить
стаття про президента і його оточення і
говорить що чиновники крадуть так
начебто завтра не
настане Та хто ж їм має пояснити що
завтра настане і завтра буде отаким у
них от де вони
будуть це має бути ті самі прокурори
детективи поліцейські
ті управління ті поліцейські які
сьогодні теж кожен день ризикують своїм
життям а управління стратегічних
розслідувань де Служба безпеки України
яка в нас бореться з контрабандою де не
ті офіцери служби безпеки які кожен день
ризикують своїм життям на передовій в
контррозвідці А ті які продовжують
ракетувати
бізнес ті які продовжують собі жити не
те що на широку ногу а те просто
страшне де
результат
де де затримані заступники голови офісу
президента Як там справи в Кирила
Тимошенка чи велике крадівництво все всі
забули відпочиває в найдорожчих барах
Києва де справи по татарову
шурме де справа по шурме по цьому пише
всьо весь світ ваш власний депутат
Тіщенко константа виступає говорить що
Шурма злодій це ж ваш це ж хум Єрмака
хто він там вам ваш найближчий А де
воно де кримінальні справи Ну щоб ми
просто зрозуміли в шурми є рідний брат в
рідного брата є сонячні електростанції
на окупованій частині Запорізької
області і державний бюджет продовжує
сплачувати за електроенергію яка в руках
ор
ми що взагалі збожеволяли чи що То як
взагалі таке може бути І це рідний брат
а його рідний брат курує всю цю систему
уявимо собі що Ми віримо Що брати
працюють окремо той бізнесмен великий а
цей великий чиновник але ж тоді це
називається щонайменше конфлікт
інтересів а де ж кримінальні справи Де
все це А де наші прокурори які отримують
по 150 000 грн зарплату де це ну цього
немає а тоді за що вони її отримують а
тоді нащо ми на це витрачаємо кошти Нащо
Ми це робимо То може нам треба все це
переглядати може нам треба робити з
цього якісь висновки давайте далі Люди
питають тридцятка наступне питання від
людей
тридцятка Ну це взагалі ганьба друзі те
що
відбулося президент України пообіцяв що
до кінця війни буде доплата в 30,000 грн
кожному кожному військовому кожному
поліцейському кожному рятувальнику
було було президент сказав поки буде
війна буде тридцятка
було було Подивіться Ніхто ж не
заперечує Ніхто ж не сказав що я щось
сказав неправду щось там прикрасив щось
не ні ніхто не Подивіться
ніхто тут з колег ніхто каже що
ну ти же брешеш цього нема Ну більша
частина знову пішла бо їм нащо тим
слухати Ну нічого ми змусимо послухати
так
ось питання А як же так що війна не
закінчилась а 30рицятка закінчилась і з
лютого місяця ніякої тридцятки нема ми з
вами Шановні колеги і тут треба віддати
належне парламенту В нас люди часто
говорять про парламент тільки поганий
але давайте чесно скажемо тут депутати
сво
роботу виконали ми виконали свою
роботу
люди мають це знати 10 квітня ми
проголосували в Верховній Раді України
питання про повернення тридцятки всім
Ще раз всім ми прийняли закон про це
закон України проголосували
тут сьогодні в нас Яке 7 листопада
красний день
календаря друзі це скільки місяців
пройшло Де
закон Чому він штучно
заблокований штучно заблокований
постановою депутата
цабаля далі не підписаний ні спікером
ні президентом
чому де він де цей
закон чому не підписуєте чому не
повертаєте людям те що пообіцяли 30 000
грн щомісячно це було обіцяно нема
коштів Вийдіть до людей чесно скажіть
чесно Давайте тоді чесну розмову как в
статті залужного The economist чесна
розмова давайте чесну розмову нема
натцтку Окей на що є на двацятку давайте
дадім дцятку але Давайте тоді знімати
все серіали
барабани незрозумілі інші речі
телемарафони давайте все знімати дороги
все давайте знімати і скажемо чесно
людям от ми все зняли все все все зняли
не вистачає на рицятку Ну але вистачає
на 20 Давайте дамо
20 Ну давайте це зробимо чому ми це не
робимо чому ми ігноруємо цю тему Чому ми
робимо вигляд що ми не знаємо взагалі
нічого про це ну так не може бути а а
люди все це дивляться люди все це бачать
і в них це викликає величез спротив і в
них це викликає питання бо ми ж говоримо
про
військових А що ж це відбувається чому
ми боронимо державу а всередині держави
з нас
знущаються бо інакше як знущанням 700
грн виведеному поза
штат назвати не можна інакше Як
знущанням дати тридцятку забрати
тридцятку поманіть тридцятка і знову
забрати це назвати не можна інакше Як
знущанням не можна звати друзі те що ми
не говоримо з вами тут про заміну наших
військовослужбовців на фронті Да я
говорю зараз про
демобілізацію А чому ми ігноруємо цю
тему чому Верховній Раді з березня
місяця лежить мій законопроект про
демобілізацію після добровільну право
дати право на демобілізацію після 18
місяців служби Ну же воно ж не винесено
навіть на комітет жодного разу
чим в нас займається Комітет з питань
національної безпеки і оборони Що з
березня місяця не зміг не знайшов часу
сили розглянути цей
законопроект чому сьогодні по Україні
мають виходити жінки мами які задають
прості питання А чому наші чоловіки
мають там бути А чому наші сини мають
там бути і ми не знаємо коли вони
повернуться
додому а для когось іншого віни
нема Ну це чесне
питання це чесне питання і не може бути
так що ми вивозимо війну на плечах одних
тих самих людей так не може бути так не
має
бути має бути
справедливість має
бути і оце питання про справедливість
давайте виносити це питання ви мені
скажете може зараз не 18 вже місяців
тому що мій закон я його вносив в
березні я якщо прийняти зараз 18 місяців
зараз може там пару сот тисяч людей піти
боєздатність війська Так це важливо
Давайте може Давайте говорити про 24
місяці давайте вводити запобіжники що
людина має Да окей 18 місяців але людина
має попередити не менш ніж за три місяці
до
давайте але ж давайте про це говорити і
давайте це виріш ти а не ігнорувати це А
ви зараз просто це ігноруєте просто
ігноруєте це начебто цього питання
просто немає Немає питання про
демобілізацію немає питання про доплати
військовим немає питання про доплату
виплату на дитину 860 грн на місяць 860
немає для вас такого питання тут
сміялися Коли я це питання ставив
розповідали що купляєте вітчизняні
памперси мені тут говорять ну так щоб не
довелося купляти памперси багатьом
політикам Коли ті хто сьогодні на фронті
повернуться додому оце щоб не було цього
це маємо всі з вами пам'ятати і думати
про це тримати це в голові Можливо тоді
багато речей проясниться і тоді багато
речей зміниться і це подивіться я от
зараз насправді в одно поки я використав
20 хвилин свого виступу Подивіться за 20
хвилин ми тут з вами засідаємо іноді
годинами цейде 20
місяців а я підняв питання надзвичайно
важливі вистачило 20 хвилин їх підняти
Ну давайте просто тоді почнемо на них
відповідати Давайте почнемо приймати
рішення на користь цих людей Давайте
почнемо приймати рішення я зараз багато
говорив про військових в мене Душа
болить за військових як я впевнений в
99% українців бо ми всі розуміємо хто
стоїть між нами і прірвою і знущання з
військових неповага до військових не
вирішення питань військових Господи Це
нещасне питання
убд ми не можемо вирішити До сих пір щоб
сотні тисяч людей які заробили на цей
статус убд учасник бойових дій отримали
нарешті цей
статус та що це
складно Чому ми маємо людину
брати і вимагати з неї пиши заяву пиши
заяву на де пиши заяву на обробку
персональних даних а далі кажуть не
можемо знайти тво бойові журнали твоєї
частини не можем те не можем це пишемо
нам не відповідають і для людини це
перетворюється в 100 ко кіл пекла
це що складно Ну що ми не знаємо хто з
людей на на нуле що в кожній частині В
кожній частині Я повідомляю вам колеги
оформлюється кожен день журнал бойових
дій даються бойові розпорядження і Кожна
частина знає по прізвищах хто в який
день був на нуле так в чому проблема це
автоматизувати людина один день була на
нуле це передбачає сьогодні закон дайте
ОБД цій людині дайте статус Дайте
документ без жодних
знущань без жодних заяв без жодних
звернень валакіти і якесь знущання Ну
просто дайте це оформіть і пришліть це в
дії Да в дії будь ласка оце можна
зробити в дії вибори в дії робити не
можна як би тут Комусь не хотілося бо
нагадаю що в нас Таємниця голосування
має бути голосування відбувається
таємно і неможливо це зробити таємно в
дії хтось буде це робити в прямому ефірі
хтось буде це робити в родинному колі
хтось з друзями за келихом пива А комусь
принесуть 1000 грн і скажуть голосуй за
цього дати ідеальна схема для підкупа Ну
просто мрія всіх хто підкуповував в
історії України то дуже просто взяв ся
дав в дії поставив А хтось може
погрожувати буде скаже от я з ножом до
тебе голосуй тисни кнопку за
цього от в дії виборів бути не може тому
що це ніякої таємниці голосування вже
мовчу про те як це буде атакувати Росія
як далі це буде хакнуто можливо і нам
оголосять що хто наш президент
Медведчук от тому не може бути виборо в
дії А ось убд в дії може бути учасник
бойових дій дати людині щоби в дії
військовий отримав без прохань без
неповаги оцієї без ходіння деякі люди з
однією ногою ходять в ттцк А де ж моє
убд А де ж моє ОБД людину вже списали а
вона не може отримати це ОБД Ну нам не
соромно ну вже ми за 20 місяців
повномасштабного вторгнення Ми не можемо
вирішити таке
елементарне елементарне
питання зовсім не складне щоб людина
отримала один раз в житті бойову доплату
отримала відповідний статус що людина
отримала не дай боже поранення одразу
моментально отримала відповідний статус
і ми повідомили цю людину друже держава
визнала твої заслуги учасник бойових дій
Невже Ми не можемо цього зробити А ми
цього не робимо і це пояснити це ну
нічим неможливо ну ніхто не може це
пояснити але на жаль цього не
відбувається А що ж відбувається Тоді
виникає питання а чим же Чим же зайнята
держава Ну от не на допомогу військовим
не вистачає сил на допомогу мамі на
дитину не вистачає сил не вистачає сил
на допомогу інваліду пенсіонеру я про
пенсіонерів зараз взагалі майже нічого
не говорив А це теж там є люди які
отримують 19900 21 22 пенсію літня
людина нездорова На жаль вже як на неї
прожити так а Чим же тоді зайнята
держава коли вона не зайнята цими людьми
а На жаль ми всі з вами побачили чим На
жаль прозвучало слово вибори і тут
одразу почався рух хочу нагадати що
спочатку президент Зеленський казав
спочатку Перемога у війні потім вибори і
ми всі це підтримували правильно Саме
так спочатку Перемога у війні
спочатку захист держави потім вибори
зараз давайте об'єднувати всі правильно
але Що Пішло далі а далі щось шло не так
тому що вже в кінці серпня президент
Зеленський на національному телемарафоні
От напевно для того щоб на нього і
витрачати 2 млрд гривень на рік 2 млрдди
ну
божевілля каже вже інше А що нам каже
президент а президент каже друзі Ви
знаєте якщо от нам гроші дадуть на
вибори і якщо надішлють спостерігачів в
окопи тоді можна вже прово дити вибори
як а все інше а а як же ж Принцип що
вибори - це боротьба один з одним і це
нормально для виборів але це ненормально
для часу війни то вже Це не має значення
далі почалися заяви шановного нашого
спікера стефанчука якого зараз немає Пан
Руслан почав казати ні конституція не
забороняє вибори хоча Конституція
забороняє вибори щонайменше
парламентські прямо а він каже ні не
забороняє
вибори тільки закон забороняє Ну а закон
же така справа можна і змінити а далі
виходить наш Міністр закордонних справ
Кулеба три дні тому і говорить вже
абсолютно прямо не те що хтось забороняє
не забороняє при яких умовах можуть бути
вибори ні Кулеба виходить і говорить
Зеленський розглядає питання проведення
виборів
весною 24го року
Опа від того що виборів немає і не буде
до перемоги до того що вони вже будуть
весною і він розглядає цю можливість і я
скажу вам я про це повідомив
українському суспільству позавчора це
викликало прямо ефект якоїсь
інформаційної бомби хоча тут в цій
сесійній залі ну покажіть мені підніміть
руку Хто не знав підніміть руку Хто не
знав що Зеленський зібрався на
вибори іти 24 березня о Вибачте 31
березня 24го року хто от є якісь колеги
які не знали Ну тоді я вам розказую
колеги Хто не
знав зібрався дав відповідні доручення
вже і почали готуватися і побіжали і вже
зараз новини виходять як навіть почали
листи приходити листи вже коли говорять
ви знаєте ніяких виборів Тут вийшов
Зеленський вчора і говорить Ті хто
вкидують в суспільство тему ви виборів
це погані люди значить це неправильно в
мене питання А чого тоді він не звільняє
колебу ну колеба міністр закордонних
справ прямі повноваження президента
України ну Володимир Олександрович
звертаюсь до вас може ви дивитесь
трансляцію хоч так будь ласка подайте
нам тоді подання на звільнення Міністра
закордонних справ кулеби бо він вніс
тему виборів що Ну ви говорите хто
вносить той значить це неправильно А
чого ж він вніс і повна Тиш
де нема Нема такого звернення нема такої
заяви більше того друзі значить вийшов
роблю рекламу виданню главком на цьому
виданні вийшла от зараз вийшов матеріал
пані Ірини
Федорів як на рівні державних
адміністрацій розсилаються термінові
телеграми про створення політичного
паспорту громад друзі політичного
паспорту громадлосували це це в нас
питання на часі політичний паспорт
громад розумієте тут ракети падають
шахеди падають а наші
політичні чим займаються політичний
паспорт громад щоб не бути голослівним
друзі то будь ласка будь ласка я вам
демонструю от будь ласка прямо тут в
ефірі прямо Вам тут всім Друзі будь
ласка
телефонограма Я
читаю голова міських селищних сільських
рад наприклад бучанського району
Київської області і начальнику
гостомильської селищної військової
адміністрації
телефонограма відповідно до усного
доручення Київської обласної державної
військової адміністрації Бучанська
районна державна військова адміністрація
просить надати дані щодо політичної
ситуації у територіальних громадах
району шляхом заповнення політи паспорту
що додається інформацію просимо
надіслати до 12 години 1 листопада 23го
року на електронну пошту відділу
комунікацій та взаємодії з органами
місцевого самоврядування
адміністрації додаток на одному аркуші в
електронному вигляді у форматі Exel
Заступник Голови адміністрації Сергій
шкут будь ласка от
qr-код от qr-код друзі є телефон
відповідальної особи така собі пані
Олена
Хоменко є мобільний телефон її наведений
що кому телефонувати от я показую на все
так Володимира Олександровича Зеленський
хто вносить тематику виборів в Україні в
суспільство хто зібрався на вибори Хто
хоче тепер нашу перемогу у війні
приміняти на свою особисту перемогу на
виборах
хто якісь незрозумілі люди якісь там
політикани чи Міністр закордонних справ
чи голови адміністрацій хто Ну І от будь
ласка до таких купа от листи головам
Білоцерківського району перший заступник
Голови адміністрації білоцерківськії
Максим
кочура ще один лист метою дослідження
терміново присилайте нам політичний
паспорт політична ситуація хто
займається
політикою
хто хто вирішив що це вже на часі під
час екзистенційної
війни та здається що це не якісь
невідомі люди і не якісь вороги а це
влада це влада просто вирішили зайнятися
цим і звичайно що якщо це є і те що ми
зараз з вами розглядаємо забрати всі
кошти в місцевих громад
о о да це ж супер політичне питання
Друзі Ну це ж супер політичне питання ми
ж з вами це чудово розуміємо на нащо
щоби якийсь міський голова депутати там
щось вирішували комусь щось допомагали
Ні давайте все заберемо сюди в Київ це ж
так класно далі можна і яйця по 17 грн і
яблука по 50 ми що не бачимо вчорашню
новину як заступнику міністра оборони на
скільки на мільярд гривень розтрата
підозра 1 млрд
грн заступнику міністра оборони України
ну колишньому Але який тут був діючий
під час
війни мільярд так що нам кажуть давайте
віддамо все на Київ хай тут поділять в
Києві та ми ж бачимо як ділять та ми ж
розуміємо як ділять ми всі розуміємо як
ділять ми всі бачимо як ділять ми бачимо
і ми розуміємо А ще це питання політики
Бо коли в тебе є гроші то ти один рука
дающа і ти вирішуєш питання Кому що скі
кільки дати Ти ніхто інший І чи це не
політика чи це не політична історія
це політика і це політична історія І це
абсолютно всім Зрозуміло Тому я
звертаюся дуже добре що коли вчора
президент Зеленський відчув після того
як ми назвали речі своїми іменами що він
готується на вибори а виборів не має
бути бо вибори - це момент
розділення на виборах люди боряться один
з одним це є нормально а під час війни
це не є нормально під час війни Це не
нормально і коли він це почув від людей
що люди не розуміють нащо вибори які
вибори Що це Що це маніпуляція що це
нещиро
що де тоді
щирість то він дав задню і вчора ввечері
він вже каже не на часі В мене питання
Скільки буде не на часі бо ми вже чули
не на часі а потім трішечки почали
просовувати що на часі Я сподіваюсь
цього разу президент буде триматися цієї
позиції не на часі до закінчення бойових
дій не на
часі не на
часі сподіваюсь але не впевнений але
обіцяю що буду за цим слідкувати і
обіцяю що все те що ви думаєте що
відбувається за зачиненими дверима і
ніхто не побачить це і Ніхто про це не
дізнається що воно так не бу
де не буде так а люди про все дізнаються
і ми все покажемо і ми розкажемо що
відбувається тому що люди мають право це
знати тому що коли ми говоримо про
бюджет Так це ж гроші людей це ж гроші
платників податків коли ми говоримо про
майбутнє держави вибори Так це ж про них
яким воно буде коли ми говоримо про
військових Та це ж той мільйон які там і
їхні родини які там з ними кожен день да
вони можуть бути фізично в Одесі у
Львові чи в
Києві але живуть вони Ці жінки разом зі
своїми чоловіками кожен вечір Кожний
ранок молячись Богу щоб вони були живі
кожне це дитина мама ми ж розуміємо це в
нас на фронті не мільйон людей в нас на
фронті мільйон родин
мільйон родин які там і це їхній фронт і
ми маємо про це людей дбати бо Вони
дбають про нас і це чесна це чесна
знаєте договір чесний ви дбаєте про нас
захищаєте нас а ми маємо подбати про вас
вони виконують свою частину
договору А
ми Чи це
є справедливо
що в той час коли виконують вони свою
частину договору Ми забираємо в них
тридцятку Чи це є справедливо що коли ви
не виконують с свою частину договору ми
платимо людині виведені поза штат 700
грн Чи це є справедливо що Ми
відмовляємось навіть говорити про
демобілізацію І заміну людей заміну
людей щоб дати можливість тим хто
виснажений Хто віддав всі свої сили на
цю хвилину бо це ж питання не тільки
фізичного здоров'я це питання морального
психічного здоров'я людина виснажується
людина не може бути безкінечно на нуле
і цій людині треба дати шанс
можливість в якихось неймовірних дебатах
тільки після годин виступів тут мені
вдалося добитися що ми розглянули
питання відпусток військовослужбовців І
хоча б дали їм ці
відпустки Але ж ми так не вирішуємо ну
Відпустка - це добре бо в деяких
військових Неві відпустки не було бо в
нуль днів тепер хоча б є 30 деяких було
10 сьогодні є 30 є час на дорогу яє за
сімейним обставино але цього мало деяких
людей вже треба міняти міняти для того
щоб зберегти їх бо людина віддала
державі що могла деякі готові воювати до
кінця і цим людям респект подяка пошана
але деякі на цю хвилину виснажилися Та
давайте їх відпустимо щоби вони
набралися знову цих сил і ми ж не знаємо
Це вже друге велике вторгнення Росії а
буде третє мож А може четверте може ми
не знаємо а хто ж захистить нас тоді
якщо ми зараз всіх цих людей
спалимо фізично і морально і психічно
хто ну Хто встане це ж вони встали хто
24 25 26 лютого пішов добровольцеям
Багато з них Це були ті хто пройшов АТО
ті хто воювали і вони нікуди не ховалися
це вони встали це вони зупинили во во
під Києвом це вони захистили Харків це
вони рятували Миколаїв це вони і вони
нікуди не збираються тікати Так ви дайте
їм можливість просто
видихнути дайте їм можливість
повернутися до родини дайте їм
можливість відновити свої сили і вони
віддадуть
сторицею вони це все повернуть вони
знову встануть за державу коли державі
це буде потрібно А ми вже побачили з
вами Що це державі є потрібно і буде
потрібно ну це же маємо ми з вами робити
І ми цього продовжуємо не робити і
Робити вигляд що нічого цього немає не
виносити ці питання в сесійну залу не
проводити складна дискусія складна
дискусія Бо людей треба замінити не
просто там хтось піде і армія впаде ні
замінити про це говорить залужни в своїй
статті The eкоonміст так людський
потенціал але Вибачте якщо ми тільки
будемо говорити це ж питання
імобілізації теж
ті хто хотів і добровольцями пішли
зрозуміло
подяка а от сьогодні чоловік який да ну
не не пішов добровольцем живе працює але
він дізнається що йому
повістка от давайте себе чесно спитаємо
для цього чоловіка те що він бачить як
відноситься держава до військових
це плюс цьому чоловіку піти
служити Ну от він знає що цим людям
пообіцяли одне а забрали була середня
зарплата виплачувалася а забрали мій
законопроект про повернення середньої
зарплати в Верховній Раді а забрали і не
розглядають і не повертають бачить що
вхід є а виходу
немає що сьогодні в нас вихід збройних
сил Це не дай боже 200хсотий чи не дай
боже
трьхсотий у в'язницю ц людину саджають
дають термін а тут його нема ну нема
терміну служби і
все нема не знаю скільки 18 24 місяці 36
48 а паралельно говорить хтось А війна
буде тривати роки
роки Так що це роки будуть одні і ті
самі люди на лінії фронту одні і ті
самі а
інші І чи це є справедливість
І чи це є повага і чи це є Стимул для
якоїсь людини піти сьогодні служити
військо коли він знає що зайшов А как
вийде не знаю якщо б ця людина знала де
чітка система має бути зайшов там В
нинішніх умовах там 12 місяців відслужив
на ротацію там я не знаю два роки тебе
не чіпають через два роки за потреби
знову повернувся військо Да але людина
має горизонт якісь планування і життя
знає що поранили тебе держава тебе
підтримує знає що може не дадуть тобі
шалену зарплату бо держава в складному
стані зруйнована економіка пустий бюджет
це все правда але знає що ти в
пріоритеті що в пріоритеті будені
марафон і серіал а в пріоритеті буде ця
людина яка взяла зброю в руки і що
можуть то дасть держава може не так
багато але не кине тебе на призволяще не
залишить тебе 700 грн після поранення Ну
тоді люди і Стимул в них буде інший пти
встати стояти захищати захищати державу
яка захищає
їх а не захищати державу якій
байдуже бо захищати тих кому байдуже теж
насправді ніхто не хоче І це правда і це
є виклик і ми маємо з ним впоратися і ми
можемо з ним впоратися для цього є
Верховна рада Для цього потрібна
дискусія давайте проводити слухання
комітетські в комі комітеті з питань
нацбезпеки і оборони Давайте давайте в
Раді проводити закриті слухання Ми і так
тут
закриті закликати сюди Міністерство
оборони генеральний штаб говорити про
цифри мобілізаційного резерву про ті
цифри які можуть піти Що ми робимо але
давайте це вирішувати ну не можна це
просто ігнорувати бо Ми створимо
проблему яку потім не вирішити
взагалі ми обвалимо все якщо ми не по
вернемося обличчям а не тим чим ваші
депутати тверк
танцюють друзі це треба пам'ятати і це
треба розуміти це треба розуміти кожен
день і і займатися Це наша з вами робота
ще раз повторююсь робота я Звертаю увагу
бачите якщо Хто там був спочатку
трансляції я звертаюсь до людей на
трансляції ви бачили скільки було
депутатів Подивіться скільки залишилось
Ну правильно от пан Степан Кубів є пан
Володимир арієв є пан Михайло бондер є
пані Роксолана підласа є А де багато
інших депутатів Чому вони пішли чи я про
щось зараз говорю я тут знаєте Не вірші
Шевченка просто читаю а я напевно говорю
про Ті теми які сьогодні болючі в
суспільстві які сьогодні це болить
кожному українцю це це теми які ми маємо
з вами рювати тему наш
Укрзалізниці в якій сьогодні зарплата
машиніста 10 000 грн яхочу ніколи такого
не було неповаги це найскладніша робота
або провідника
45 тема наших вчителів якого сьогодні
молодого вчителя до мене включаються
люди кажуть Я молодий вчитель 5 000 грн
зарплата пть
це ми Дбаємо про
майбутнє чи медична сестра включається
говорить 4 з по медична сестра 4500
грн Ну як на це жити Ну як і одночасно
вони чують прокурор 14 40 000
грн і дивляться на свадьбу прокурора і
дбрівки чи навпаки прокурорки і дбрівця
які заздрять арабські
шейхи Ну вони ж не сліпі люди не глухі
Вони ж все це бачать і ми маємо
відповідати ми можемо не дати ідеальну
відповідь Але ми маємо дати якусь
відповідь і хоч щось покращувати і хоч
щось зробити якийсь крок ще півкрока ще
півкрока на тих можливостях які ми
сьогодні маємо і звичайно Друзі Ну
супертема важлива це тема боротьба з
корупцією тому що сьогодні Ну коли це
виходе оцей журнал Тайм і словами Про те
що крадуть так що наче завтра не настане
в Україні а далі що ми вдивуємося ну це
читають люди в нью-йорку в пенсилвені
Огайо
оклагома а далі їм говорить там
президент Байден каже Давайте допоможемо
Україні і подяка президенту байдену за
це каже Давайте допоможемо от давайте
грошей туди дамо а сидить якийсь платник
податків і каже стоп стоп стоп стоп Це
кому ми маємо дати тій країні де як
написав журнал Тайм крадуть так що наче
завтра не настане щоб вони їх вкрали ми
розуміємо наскільки це катастрофічна є
оця стаття і це питання яке прозвучало в
світі ми сьогодні маємо Це негайно
виправити негайно і ми можемо це зробити
для цього Нам не потрібен Байден Трамп
нам не треба до них звертатися нам не
треба чекати щось від світу нарешті
відкрити розслідування по всьому тому що
знає вся країна останній аудит
рахункової палати Міністерство оборони
завищені Ціни на харчування це вже це ж
навіть вже не журналістські
розслідування негайно позвільняти тих по
кому є питання Шурма та Татаров Агов
геть відкриті справи Тимошенко Кирил
інші
Привет показати цьому всьому світу що
тут все розслідується і навіть якщо
хтось щось вкрав таке буває в будь-якій
країні світу питання тільки в одному чи
знайдуть чи візьмуть за одне місце чи
ні так давайте покажемо що знайдуть
візьмуть гроші повернуть і тоді нам і
проблем з підтрим нашою буде набагато
менше а в іншому випадку як пише той
самий журнал Тайм півроку ігнорувалася
тема яєць по 17 грвень аж допоки ми тут
нарешті не розглянули питання відставки
міністра оборони резнікова Хоча йому
нагадаю колеги слуги народу стоячи тут
аплодували коли він заходив і коли він
йшов за що стоячи аплодували Я не дуже
розумію може вони знають за
що Ну я не знаю народ України не зна
і не може бути єдиним покаранням
звільнення не може мають бути
розслідування що там з бакановим Куди
він зник голова СБУ під час
вторгнення коли ми розуміємо ворог
пройшов взяв південь як де було СБУ чому
не взривалися мости чому це все
проспалося і сьогодні нам говорять в
керівництві СБУ була ячейка
ФСБ так А де ж тоді питання до баканова
баканова звільнили по статті що він так
страшне наробив президент звільнив по
статті
дисциплінарної А де ж розслідування чого
ми нічого про це не знаємо чому остання
новина яку ми почули про баканова що
Раптом він став адвокатом в Полтавській
області все ми більше нічого не знаємо
про баканова ми де справи Де
розслідування як що ні тиша Ну так тоді
не буде результату не буде підтримки не
буде буде нічого тому що ті люди які
несуть пряму відповідальність пряму
прямісеньку Вони мають за це ну мають за
це відповісти і мають пояснити і
показати суспільству що є і
як друзі я хочу от всім цим пояснити що
питання яке ми розглядаємо прямо зараз
це до речі питання 100 млрд грнь забрати
100 млрд грнь в місцевих бюджетів це до
речі теж питання Кору тому що що чи хочу
я сказати що наші місцеві бюджети
ідеальні що там нема корупції що вони не
витрачають кошти на бруківку стадіони та
ми ж бачимо як і люди виходять по країні
і у Львові і в Одесі в інших містах
виходять і говорять да припиняйте
витрачати гроші на Дурню витрачайте на
армію але хто подав приклад їм як не
Центральна влада серіалами барабанами
хто хто цей приклад
подав і тому якщо сьогодні ми хочемо
щоби це реально місцева Влада витрачала
всі кошти на армію так давайте зробимо
дуже просто і чесно і тут є такі
поправки от серед цих поправок які ми
розглядаємо 1600 є низка поправок в тому
числі мої які говорять А давайте просто
обмежимо не будемо забирати кошти в
місцевого самоврядування а обмежимо
напрям використання військового ПДФО
армію допомогою армії бо є громади які
допомагають армії навіть більше ніж ті
те ПДФО військове яке їм надходить є
такі громади і подяка їм а є громади які
нехтують А є громади які вирішили що це
їм впала на голову мана небесная і вони
зараз її собі поділять як їм завгодно і
по кишенях розтащуть Так але проти цього
не закон має бути що забрати кошти всіх
а проти цього має бути закон обмежити це
і все державне казначейство ніколи не
пропустить жодні видатки якщо вони
будуть іти у протиріччя з законодавством
України яке ми з вами визначаємо ми як
народні депутати так давайте це зробимо
чесно прозоро
відкрито Я мовчу про те що ми
розглядаємо закон щоб забрати кошти
місцевого самоврядування з 1
жовтня жовтня
ще раз 1
жовтня цього року в нас сьогодні 7
листопада щось мені підказує що коли я
завершу свій виступ дуже хотілося б щоб
головуючий поставив вже і закон на
голосування Ну що ж Хочеться вірити що
головуючий не закриє наше засідання і не
скаже тепер розійшлися бо тут депутати
порозходилися Ну от ми проголосуємо цей
закон я за нього голосувати не буду але
я так дивлюсь що настрій є як кажуть
Потенціал є бо забрати в когось кошти на
це потенціал знайти легко проголосують
Далі щось мені підказує будуть постанови
про оскарження далі там поки підпишуть
далі будуть поспішати Звичайно все одно
закон буде остаточно підписаний ну в
другій половині листопада не
раніше поясніть мені як можна забрати в
другій половині листопада кошти з 1
жовтня
Да Вже ні в мене рекорд буде більше 90
хвилин я йду це Антон ти неправильно
побачив значить як можна ще раз забрати
кошти з 1
жовтня заднім числом Я кажу на
бюджетному комітеті представникам уряду
А може заберете з 1 жовтня 2018 року і
мені заступник Міністра відповідає гарна
ідея каже добра ідея
подобається Ну ми же дорослі люди в нас
ну є родини все ну от ви в своїй родині
ви вже витратили кошти в жовтні і раптом
до вас хтось приходить в листопаді каже
Ану
поверни Та це як та в тому числі на тих
самих військових віддали вже так це як
ну це що за держава в якій Можуть
сказати з 1 жовтня давай
Назад Ну це ж божевілля
А в нас це зараз в законі Це закон
України які колеги збираються
проголосувати прийняти і жити по ньому А
що це за сигнали кому взагалі як тут
щось можна в країні планувати як можна
щось робити Ну як
як ну це якись ну страшний Я не знаю
савок якийсь чи що Що ми будем заднім
числом що верховенство права
нема це важливі речі тому що ну з таких
правил починається Все та правил
починається все з боротьби з корупцією
починається все і ви знаєте в кожній
ситуації можна це знайти На жаль от мені
зараз люди дуже багато пишуть 128
ми ж з вами розуміємо про що йде
мова мова йде про 128 бригаду і трагедію
яка з нею сталася страшна трагедія це
коли Це совкове
построєние 30 км від лінії фронту
зачекайте
командуючого
поки
чекали дочекалися російську
ракету вбиті герої поранені герої шок в
усій
країні А давайте будемо чесними це що
вперше це вперше такі в нас
необов'язкові втрати тому що просто не
було інших прильотів по навчальних
центрах казармах
де ніхто чомусь не подумав який це є
ризик
А чому так а тому що ми сьогодні чуємо
командир 128ї бригади відсторонений від
своєї посади А питання до інше А як
командиром 128ї бригади стала людина яка
в 19-му році була засуджена за
контрабанду
цигарок
засуджено за контрабанду
цигарок і на той момент комбати
підполковник В 19-му році комбати
підполковник став 23му комбрігом і
полковником Ну оце можна спитати Ну це ж
це цікаве питання хто призначив вже
після 19го року цю людину після вироку
що людина ну боє різні офіцери бо є
різні депутати бо є різні хто завгодно є
офіцери які ну взірець А є офіцери які А
є офіцери які займалися абсолютно іншим
контрабандою шування отдивіться Там
хтось кричить незрозуміло Хто це це там
в нас такі є Ну в нас в Раді є різні
люди і тут є і клоунада є і константи є
і рекетири і от там кричить людина яка
власне такою людиною є це друзі збудився
рекетр тіщенка і рекетір тищенка щось
кричить там ганьба думаю що він візьме
репліку і нам скоро пояснить це правду
про свій рекід про конста
про колцентри про ліс про вкрадене про
карантин про вілюр про все все все інше
О бачите да добре коли ви дивіться люди
коли бачите оце тіщенка отам сидить в
кінці І оце кричить ви його бачите
заховався там за
колоною за колоною заховався пане
Володимире Можна вас попросити показати
людям трішки ближче що це він кричить
Дякую вам хто там кричить дякую вам дуже
от зараз покажемо що це він там
кричить безпосередньо пан Тіщенко так от
друзі це дуже цікаве питання до речі що
такі люди як він роблять ще в Верховній
Раді не сидять у в'язниці сидять не
сидять у в'язниці тіщенка сидить а
сидить в залі Верховної Ради ще кричить
і от з цього починається все з того коли
в Верховній Раді сидять люди якім місце
у в'язниці деякі слуги народу зараз це в
СІЗО зустрічають я такий слуга народу
Гунько він в СІЗО він там тримає гріє
гріє шконку і для тіщенка в мене нема
сумнівів і для багатьох колег о ви вже
тут це нько друзі нько вже з нами ви я я
я не знав цього Господи прости
Гунько Тут друзі Він вже не в СІЗО друзі
народний депутат нько це той якого
набузна значить показала кадри як взяла
сумкою грошей 80 000 доларів який тут в
нас разом з тіщенка був голова слідчої
комісії Тищенко по лісах А цей по земле
сільськогосподарский
ми йому ще Привет передавали з трибуни в
СІЗО друзі ура Гунько
повернувся ура друзі Гунько з нами він
тут все СІЗО закінчилося не треба друзі
фантастика Гунько вже
тіщенка в Верховній Раді фантастика
Юрченка якого брали Тож напевно десь тут
сидить Юрченка теж тут сидить з нами ні
якого брали на цьому на плюшках 200 000
доларів якого перед тим вкрав декілька
пляшок пива з магазина а потім став
народним депутатом він теж тут я розумію
Юрченка друзі Так скажіть мені всі
ганьба я прошу Гунька тіщенка Юрченка
дати обов'язково якусь репліку ну дати
репліку якусь після того Пусть розкажуть
нам як досвід в них є як віджимати гроші
або розкажуть яке неправильне і погане
набу це це фантастика друзі от ви от
зараз друзі Ви в прямому ефірі Бачите що
тут
відбувається в прямому ефірі ви бачите
Подивіться Просто ви прямо Ви побачили
чому в країні от весь цей без о вон вон
вон он цей клоун став дивіться чому
такий безлад чому Тому що такі як
Тіщенко сидять в Верховній Раді а не у
в'язниці о От дивіться дивіться такий
Гунько вже повернувся тобто Уявіть собі
і людина спокійно говорить так а чо ти
там кажеш ти вотн я Гунько Я є
тебе заарештували за хабаря набу А ти
кажеш Да ні Я тут вже є який то все
нормально Ні ких питань нема Друзі Ну Це
божевілля це божевіл Ну що ми показуємо
лю ну я я я я я не знаю друзі Ану
давайте Хто хоче щось сказати нашим
депутатам ми ще зараз спробуємо почути
безпосередньо
людей і да да да І оце я думаю що є люди
які теж хотіли би щось сказати народним
депутатам які які от бачать от весь цей
от весь цей безлад і і давайте друзі
хтось з наших
військових да значить Давайте ми
спробуємо ви можете собі уявити що
відбувається Просто от люди пишуть от
Люди зараз сидять і пишуть одне на ноль
на ноль Ну так ійди такі оце оці Крикуни
такі Подивіться От куди їм треба всім
правильно на ноль ну це ту такі бачите
які мають такі фантастичні си хочеться
друзі якогось з наших військових може
знаєте щоб почули
почули да І це і це мені здається було
би дуже-дуже
потрібно друзі якщо це в нас хтось з
військових то скажіть що це військові і
ми дамо вам щось сказати теж бо Бачите
що тут
відбувається ви
військовий друзі Так зараз можливо Ми
якраз і почуємо Когось з наших
військових вони давно хотіли щось
сказати в Верховній Раді України може
сього Зараз ми їм і дамо таку
безпосередню можливість щоб вони сказали
прямо з нуля що Вони
думають от от прямо з нуля би сказали і
і це і це було би безумовно Я думаю
потрібно і важливо почути тому що як ви
бачите що в цій Верховній Раді
відбувається абсолютно не те чого від
цієї Верховної Ради очікують люди і що
мало б бути ви військовий
так бачите щось тут нас не дають нам
з'єднати якого військового щоби
військовий нам щось сказав про з приводу
тих людей от які тут себе отак поводять
і і таке роблять Друзі Ну поки ми
спробуємо Я обов'язково продовжу ту
думку яка
є Добрий день ви
військовий Олексій олевич вас чують
Верховна Рада України да я при всій
повазі у нас немає такої форми роботи
яку ви заразхо намагайтесь зробити Ми
радо чекаємо військових всіх в цій залі
і я думаю завжди 226 на участь
військових буде коли буде коли буде 226
в залі тому пропоную повернутися до
вашої порне друзі не хочуть почути Вій
Олексій олексівич секундочку Микола
Миколайович там решта колег давайте
все-таки не порушувати порядок в залі і
потім у всіх буде право на репліку і
усіх вище означених осі будь ласка Добре
Добре тоді я насправді щоби підтримати
наших колег якім щоби дати їм можливість
Ну що називається всіх було право на
репліку шановні друзі Ну Вибачте
військових бачите кажуть нема такої
форми роботи що почути військового я
хотів вас включити Ну тоді може тільки
ваші те що ви напишете можу цитувати і
ваші питання ставити але тут прозвучало
що колеги значить будуть репліки то
хотілося б почути репліки і від інших і
від інших наших колег хотілося б почути
репліку від пана гіть цева нашого колеги
який тричі був помічником сівковича
сівковича сьогодні СБУ говорить що це
очільник російської агентурної мережі в
Україні значить а тричі його помічником
був народний депутат Данило гітьманцев
от даю теж можливість право на репліку
пану Данилу
безумовно Хто тут ще Юрченко згадував це
Гунько сказав когось ще люди якщо хочуть
почути пишіть мені я згадаю може вони
знайдуть собі час та сили дати якусь
відповідь пан сабаль який заблокував
своєю постановою виплати військовим
думаю теж йому теж є що сказати це було
би чудово від нього почути його репліку
в нас Ну тут є багато депутатів яких би
дуже би хотіли почути люди тож я вам
всім даю таку можливість щоби ви
розповіли що і як відбувається і Чому
все так
відбувається тепер друзі я продовжу Ми
сьогодні говоримо з вами про бюджет
держави Щоб виглядало Так що я говорю
знаєте про проблемні питання але не
говорю а як же їх вирішити Да Ну дійсно
можна сказати Ну а що Ну там проблеми ми
всі бачимо але як їх вирішувати Ну деякі
проблеми я сьогодні чітко сказав як їх
вирішувати проблема військових я сказав
потрібен закон про заміну тобто
демобілізацію одних І заміну
їх подав такий законопроект давайте
розглядати Давайте визначатися я
пропоную шляхви вирішення а не просто
кажу що там погано Так всі знають що там
погано але отак можна вирішити подав
законопроект про ротацію бо є підрозділи
які на нуле 20 місяців Вони теж не не не
не сталеві да це ми говоримо наші
сталеві воїни з металу але навіть метал
втомлюється давайте вирішувати питання
ротації відпрацювали три місяці на нулі
захистили державу відійшли хоча б на
місяць відпочили Ну так воно має бути і
так було обіцяно На жаль цього для
багатьох підрозділів немає тому це теж
пропозиція А що робити що робити з
економікою от нам говорять от що робити
да
економічно Ну я скажу що робити з
економікою треба ставити в воглаву угла
не що інше не податки не як витиснути
гроші не рекіт не змінювати ці податки
500 разів на рік а поставити головне
робоче місце і будь-який підприємець
який створює робоче місце та треба його
тільки підтримати максимально не просить
нічого від держави платить зарплату
людям слава Богу а ще з цього якісь
ідуть податок подоходний щонайменше от
той який ви зараз хочете поділити Ви що
ж хочете забрати ви хочете забрати
податок з доходів фізичних осіб це той
зарпла це той податок який забирається з
зарплати кожної людини
ПДФО І як це створити цей податок І як
це дати людям цю зарплату дати її цю
зарплату людям А для цього їй треба щоби
наше наступне питання тут в Верховній
Раді буде повернути перевірки на бізнес
друзі вони ще хочуть повернути перевірки
на
бізнес правильно ч ж мало нашим
податківцям себе погано я так розумію
почувають ще більшим давайте створимо
можливісті відрекетувати бізнес всі ці
бюро економічної безпеки податкова
служба всі ці безкінечні які ходять
вимагають
забирають Друзі Ну це же Ну це ж
реальність ми ж всі з вами це знаємо так
може нам з вами От вам і відповідь А що
треба робити да
навпаки забороняти ці перевірки цей беп
в тому вигляді Якій сьогодні Він працює
Він взагалі жодної користі не приносить
то ще витрачаємо на нього сотні
мільйонів забрати ці кошти дати
можливість тим хто створює робоче місце
не чіпати їх не чіпати Їх абсолютно А Що
робимо ми ми робимо абсолютно інші речі
це в питанні економічної і і це є дуже
важливим що робити нам в питанні
зовнішньої політики де дуже складно
сьогодні дуже складно та нарешті
розкрити потенціал Верховної Ради
перестати займатися дурньой коли тут
сидить і спікер визначає кому можна
їхати за кордон кому не можна тільки
якось так виявляється щок коли слуги
народа то якось ще їм не можна а на
Мальдівах вони опиняються дивним чином в
Тайланді опиняються дивним чином в
іншихмі місцях опиняються дивним чином А
коли ти хочеш їхати захищати країну
працювати наприклад як я там в
парламентській асамблеї Ради Європи Ні
не пущать бо забагато говориш Бо
забагато питань в тебе і не подобаєшся
Ти нам і не будемо ми тут Ти що
ти посягнув на святе сказав про
стипендію батьку Зеленського та після
того ти взагалі куди там що ми тебе тут
Ох таке тобі влаштуємо щоб значи тебе і
місця не було Ну тому що я не знаю це
окрема історія Так Ми не почули
відповідь на це жодної чому нащо чи хто
підставив президента цією стипендією
батько якщо не підставив чому не
відмовляє ну це же абсурд ну ну це якісь
то ми ми розповіли сьогодні як важко
людям А в той же час батько президента
довічна
стипендія при всій повазі ну ну ну слава
богу Ну в нього син в змозі підтримати
батько так як треба в нього всі для для
цього є можливості нащо від держави ці
там 6,000 грн то давайте віддамо ну є
тим кому вони сьогодні потрібніше ну
правда же Ну це речі з яких все
починається які бачать люди з яких вони
роблять висновки про все про нас з вами
про відношення про ситуацію в країні ми
маємо ж з вами про це пам'ятати маємо ж
з вами про це говорити Давайте е не не
дали мені можливістьі включити людей
тоді я спробую поставити питання от
пишуть Люди де мобілізація от я те що
пишуть люди демобілізація
тридцятка зарплати
а
кордони де де депутати дуже багатьох
турбує питання А де депутати Ну я не
знаю колеги де депутати от Куди вони всі
розійшлись в нас сьогодні сьогодні 7
листопада другий робочий день Верховної
Ради В цьому
місяці ніяк у військових яких немає
вихідних ніяк в лікаря Чи вчителя яки
там п'ятиден робочий тиждень в нас
другий робочий день за сім днів в перший
день в суботу в нас тут було 17
депутатів зараз в нас тут можливо 30
депутатів ну було тільки що тут напевно
депутатів 200 скільки закінчиться до
завершення А це ж ми з вами сьогодні о
котрій почали О 12-й це ми ще двох годин
не працюємо А чого так втомлюється така
втомленість такась втома хронічна втома
в депутатів таки складна історія що вони
не можуть ну якби витримати 860 грн люди
ну це на дітей Це очевидно це всі ну
Тіщенко зрадник Зрозуміло Значить тут
нема
питань далі Ну 128 бригада ну сподіваюсь
буде розслідування і більше це ніколи не
повториться такий жах це звичайно
трагедія
н люди пишуть в них не втома наперед да
ну це 100%
втома втома наперед робочі місця пишуть
люди пишуть люди робочі місця дайте нам
де ми будемо працювати і миї повернемось
за кордону пишуть люди але ж ми хочемо
працювати пишуть що 100 не
отримують от військовий пише 500 грн
прийшла зарплата мені От пише військовий
напевно виведений поза штат от ну що ну
що що відповісти цій людині От що мені
сказати цій людині Ну от я не знаю От я
кажу депутату Сьогодні я про це сказав
10 рів ми зможемо вирішити просте
питання людей які виведені поза штат
наших військових вже Ну давайте їх не
будемо викидати на
жебракування ну ну не 500 же гривень Ну
не 500 грн на місяць Ну це ж неможливо
жити за
це ціна на газ пишуть люди
питання озброєння Да Ну що з озброє ну
це це все важливі питання Чому працює
укрволонте терпром чому працює
мінволонтер і чому на жаль Ну ми не
бачимо достатньо з нашого укроборонпрому
від нашого Міноборони бо це питання
виживання держави і про це пише
заолужний В своїй статті в The
eконоomist і ми розуміємо все ми
розуміємо що там якби все складно До
речі зверніть увагу це теж Вже показово
залуж не пише статті він не пише там
жодної критики на адресу президента чи
офісу президента і правильно і це не
може і не має такого бути Він
головнокомандувач президент верховний
головнокомандувач Але після статті
виходить заступник рмака пан Жовква на
екрани національного телемарафону і
критикує залужного Я не розумію взагалі
цього навіть якщо Ну я не не хочу
входити може щось там не так вирішіть
питання За зачиненими дверима нащо ви
всьому світу показуєте що в вищому
військово-політичному керівництві
України є щонайменше тертя
Нащо це нам потрібно нащо ви це ж на
телемарафоні нічого випадково не буває
друзі туди ніхто випадково не потрапляє
якщо він там з'явився значить це було
потрібно а далі питання як звільнили
командуючого ссо це ж в той же самий
день сигнал без цього він командувач ссо
каже я дізнався про своє звільнення каже
з медіа то сидів планував військові
операції і тут дізнаюся Хто ти вже ніхто
ти
звільнений генерал командуюч сил
спеціальних операцій ми що взагалі
збожеволяли Як таке може бути
Ні там Кого звільняти хто має бути
командуючим ссо вирішувати Верховному
головнокомандувачу йому видніше але ж не
можна звільняти людину щоб вона
дізналась про це з медіа медіа тобто з
інтернету добре що він був підписаний на
якийсь telegramканал бажано Гончаренко і
дізнався звідти А якщо б ні щоби керував
якийсь би час Ну це ж ну ми ну це що
взагалі як таке в країні може бути от в
принципі як може бути таке в країні це
теж же попидання поваги до тих самих
військовослужбовців це все починається з
рядового якого виводять поза Штати
платять 700 грн до генерала якому дають
копняка про що він дізнається з
інтернету
ну з пояснення слів як це чому це друзі
що в нас відбувається ну Як таке може
бути як може бути
мені Я вчора був в Рівному в Луцьку в
нітішині я хочу сказати мене це мені
здається в Рівному мене спитали ні в
Луцьку Вибачте в Луцьку мене спитали
люди і розказали історію там схопили
жінку яка вкрала шматок сала і їй дали
5ть років два місяц
в'язниці Це була вже не перша її там На
жаль крадіжка супермаркета і крадіжка є
крадіжка але за Шматок сала їй дали 5
років пять років в'язниці
а народні депутати яких ловили на хабарі
80 000 доларів говорять а ми тут
в нас все добре а люди до яких є питання
на мільярди в них все добре все добре за
Шматок сала 5ть років за
мільярди державна нагорода ще герої
України можуть дати чого ні Це ж напевно
величезни цей і Оце і є величезна
проблема яка ну ну нас вбиває просто нас
вбиває І це те що що створює розколює
суспільство це те що викликає дуже
багато питань це те чому ми сьогодні
маємо ті проблеми які ми маємо і їх
треба вирішувати і якщо ми з вами Далі
будемо їх ігнорувати якщо замість цього
ми будемо ламати всіх через коліно якщо
замість цього ми
будемо просто нікого не чути і нічого не
чути Ну буде катастрофа і біда я сказав
що я зараз кажу що треба робити Я вже
назвав речі економічна політика з
пріоритетом на робоче місце реальна
антикорупційна боротьба реальна ні за
Шматок сала на 5ть років а нарешті
взятися за тих хто краде мільярди або
мільйони реальні речі вся інфраструктура
створена набу є сап є суд
антикорупційний є всі є гроші в них є
закони є все є Хай працюють Хай
показують результат Бо коли я бачу
новину на сайті набу що вони відправили
справу в суд за те що викрали насіння на
3 мльона гривень це дві фури насіння там
чи що А в той же час я не чую ніяких
новин по тому як голова
Дніпропетровської обласної військової
адміністрації 1 млрди гривень підрядів
на дорогах Минулого року ще під час вже
війни віддавав
фітнес-інструктору її компанії яка потім
якось дивним збігом обставин з ним разом
їздить за кордон перетинає кордон ну
відна тренується постійно
разом і 1 мльрди гривень їй віддають а
результат цієї справи Ми не чуємо А де
вона Ну це ж не Шматок сала правда це 15
млрди гривень а де воно то це Наступне
Що має бути зроблено в державі
наступне але я на цьому не
зупиняюся я говорю наступну важливу річ
ми сказали що вибори не на часі і слава
богу і сподіваємось що влада схминулася
і припинеть цим займатися А що ж тоді на
часі друзі а на часі дійсно єднання А як
же цього єднання добитися А я скажу вам
в нас на початку цього
вторгнення багато людей в світі
порівнювали президента Зеленського з
черчелем казали От черчель він там цей і
для України Я зараз не Входжу там є
питання що називається Щодо цієї
схожості але для України це було добре
насправді добре порівняння Тому що весь
світ ну черчель історична постать і коли
говорять Україну веде сильний лідер
супер Ну добре Це це добре для країни Я
ніколи ніде за кордоном не ставив під
сумнів це порівняння а навпаки Да да
конечно тому що це для
країни але давайте будемо чесними І
скажемо декілька речей Перша а що ж
зробив той справжній черчель
ні цей наш черчель а той черчель Коли
став прем'єр-міністром в травні 40-го
року в момент найбільших випробувань
екзистенційного виклику для
Великобританії Він запросив опозицію він
покликав
етлі лідера опозиції стати своїм
заступником він об'єднав весь парламент
Великобританії 600 людей до речі думаю
що парламент Великобританії тоді краще
ходив на роботу ніж сьогодні ходить
парламент України як ми бачимо в суботу
то було 17 людей Зараз людей 30
перевтома і всіх їх об'єднав була одна
коаліція величезна виборів в
Великобританії не було між
1935 і
1945 роком країна займалася перемогою До
речі після перемоги черчель програв
вибори ну це життя і демократія але 10
років виборів ніяких не було і ніхто не
ставив під питання легітимність черчеля
щось цей ніяких питань не було Бо вся
країна
об'єдналася всі разом нема нікого хто
викреслений що зробив нетаньяху
прем'єр-міністр Ізраїля коли після
жахливих подій 7 жовтня
е коли там був цей напад і вбиті люди і
катастрофа при тому що в Ізраїлі в нас
тут теж ми всі не дуже любимо один
одного але в Ізраїлі рівень політичної
ненависті Мені здається навіть вище ніж
в Україні Ну так збоку дивлячись це
колосальний рівень Да дякую колега
приніс мені пляшку води оце справдній
товариш і друг колега депутат Саврасов
так ось друзі так ось друзі що зробив
нетаньяху
нетаньяху покликав
опозицію доєднатись до нього в уряді
перше Що він зробив при тому що ми
розуміємо з вами Що напад хамас на
Ізраїль не становить екзистенційну
небезпеку для Ізраїля ну не може хамас
знищити
Ізраїль а Росія на
жаль ну могла знищити Україну сподіваюсь
же не може Але це був екзистенційний
виклик і залишається їм для нас ну Точно
Що Ну не порівняти хамас з
Путіним Ну да Та з точки зору що вони
вбивають терористи Да але не не
порівняти з точки зору небезпеки ядерна
держава на нас напала І що зробив наш
черчель маргіналізував
опозицію всіх
відтиснив парламент перетворив Ну ми ж
нічого тут не вирішуємо реально Ну це ж
просто тут сидять тиснуть кнопочку
реально з парламенту здається є одна
людина яка може зайти в кабінет
президента її зараз тут
немає Є ще дві людини які напевно можуть
по робочих питаннях хоч якось може наш
спікер і його перший заступник можуть
Хоч там постукатись може їм хтось щось
відповість все все в Раді президента ми
не бачимо якщо він приходить Ну тільки
виступити нам виступив і пішов Ми
заспівали хором вірьовки він послухав
пішов
а нема контакту нема ніякого я звернувся
до президента листом по закону це ж
питання статусу народного депутата
народний депутат має право на
прийом будь-якого керівника я зробив
запит на президента хочу попросив Я
вимагаю зустрічі за п'ятий рік
президентство Зеленського а паралельно я
народний депутат Я попросив один раз
Дайте мені одну годину я хочу поставити
питання донести ситуацію розповісти те
що мені здається важливим що може вам
Єрмак це не
розповідає може ви цього не
знаєте повна тиша ніхто навіть не
відповідає мені я навіть офіційної
відповіді не отримав Я так розумію Єрмак
це відправив подалі Ну ясно що далі
відправив сказав там де знов на мене
щось шукають бо це в наші органи можуть
виконувати політичні завдання побіжали
щось шукають бо цей бачите що він хоче
зустрічатися якісь питання ставити ну да
бо я теж представник народу України як і
президент і хочу поставити і хочу
розказати іде немає уряд наш Та я вже Па
пан шмигаль багато людей в країні ви
знаєте я проводив експеримент я в стрімі
спитав хто знає прізвище
прем'єра
ніхто ніхто не знає прізвище прем'єра
України шмигаль нагадую
шмигаль ми його не бачили місяцями Нам
сказали повернеться година запитань до
уряду один раз він прийшов посидів
годину це за 20 місяців ні уже скоро 21
і пішов
все на цьому поки все закінчилося де він
де вони нуце ми це об'єднання це черчель
це екзистенційний виклик Ну це ж всім
можна дати роботу Ну скільки людей в
країні там дайте роботу всім от не ріште
завдання Верховна Рада має своє там А ви
ну треба ж тоді просто відпустити треба
не їсти в один рот і треба не думати що
ти один Богом
поцілований бо кожна людина може
помилятися і кожна людина може щось ну
зробити або не
зробити правильно Ні неправильно Мені
здається що Зеленський навіть не розуміє
взагалі а на що потрібен парламент Мені
здається що в його думка що це взагалі
якесьбіговиська нікому не потрібна На
жаль багато колег яких він сюди і привів
і змушують людей може його самого думати
Так що це якесь біговисько нікому не
потрібне друзі парламент тільки я хочу
нагадати і нашим глядачам Чому важливий
парламент та Подивіться на будь-яку
успішну країну вона Парламентська або це
взагалі Парламентська президентська
держава або там сильний парламент як в
Сполучених Штатах Америки сильним
президентом але сильний
парламент чому та тому що це механізм
балансу це певні стримування і противаги
це діалог Це дискусія хтось один розуміє
на військовій справі хтось іншій на
Медичній хтось третій на освіті і так
виробляється експертиза на країну А які
в нас тут з вами дискусії їх нема Ми не
дискутуємо ні в комітетах ми не
дискутуємо в залі бо нам що прийшли
проголосували кнопочку натисли пішли
далі все пишеться в одному місці в офісі
президента і в принципі ніхто не
потрібен всім керує дві людини і і я так
розумію їм так зручно але вони роблять
величезну помилку Єрмак і Зеленський
коли вони по-перше це колосальна
відповідальність яку вони теж взяли на
себе а по-друге вони викреслюють
колосальну частину суспільства з
можливості впливати на
ситуацію міняти ситуацію відчувати що
вони потрібні і помилки стають
неминучими і помилки стають незворотніми
а платимо за це все ми і Україна
сьогодні платить колосальну ціну за все
це колосаль ну друзі це дуже важливі
питання які я ставлю Да я розумію
що багато хто Да розійшлись депутати не
хочуть чути не хочуть бачити але
друзі ми я буду змушувати чути Я буду
змушувати бачити бо в нас інших
варіантів нема Країна має бачити правду
Країна має знати правду Країна має в
впливати на політиків ми маємо їх
витверезлювати як це зробили з виборами
і це є дуже добре що заставили примусили
схаменутися так і далі ми маємо це
робити В мене прохання до пана Артура
герасімова В мене прохання колего я
прошу вас от з моїх правок там обрати
декілька важливих правок які
стосуються грошей військовим або тим щоб
це не було заднім числом щоб які ми
поставили на голосування в кінці мого
виступу бо я хочу все-таки щоб ми всі
продемонстрували
потенціал показали скільки в нас тут є
депутатів показали реально картину
Скільки тих хто ще не так втомився за
другий робочий день в місяць і за ми
працювали 7 листопада з 14:30 до 23ї це
8, по годин ну звичайний вісьмигодинний
робочий день Зараз в нас йде наша робота
вже дві години ну 10,5 годин за тиждень
місяця Ну напевно можна попрацювати і не
так вже перевтомитися що руки терпнуть
ноги
відмовляють і нема сил і нічого ні
працювати ні слухати Ну так Напевно це
було би правильно і показати Хто є Хто і
показати ці голосування і викласти їх
обов'язково всюди щоб люди побачили а
хто ж все-таки ходить на роботу А хто
все-таки вважає що це робота і що
роботою треба займатися що якщо вчитель
не прийде на роботу його викинуть якщо
військовий не прийде на роботу то
взагалі
цей
а тому от от ситуація яку ми друзі маємо
і і Вона вимагає іншої якості роботи
парламенту вони вимагає реального
об'єднання в стилі черчеля а не
фейкового об'єднання на жаль в стилі
Зеленського і і давайте Поки не пізно
зробимо висновки ситуація в країні дуже
складна ситуація на фронті складна і це
говорю не я це говорить
головнокомандувач залужний ситуація в
економіці надскладна і коли виходить
дослідження що Україна серед дев'яти
країн найгірших по оподаткуванню Привіт
гетьманцеву
докерувалися дев'ять країн податкового
пекла ми попали в цей
перелік коли ситуація в міжнародній
політиці надскладна коли допомога і
підтримка України зависла коли вчора
міністр фінансів України говорить що в
нас може бути дирка в 29 млрд доларів
США ми уявляємо взагалі що це за цифра
це означає обвал гривні це означає що ну
це Це катастрофа Так це означає що
терміново це треба виправляти в цей
момент треба працювати в цей момент
треба
робити правильні кроки схаменутися і
врятувати країну як ми це робили
об'єднавшись 20 місяців тому ще не пізно
це зробити я дякую Я хочу поставити на
голосування наступні правили які номери
будь
ласка дайте ще раз
Гончаренко дякую дякую тут просять набіс
ну зробимо і набіс якось а поки про про
по поправки поправка 1346
це про заходи і Куди Оце поправка яка
вирішує Все я пояснюю зараз коротко цю
поправку і на одній цій поправці більше
навіть не будемо і Ці дві все три да три
поправки І все я пояснюю Чому вони
важливі значить це поправка
1346 1632 і 1633 на цьому крапка Це
поправка яка говорить Не забирайте
нічого в місцевого самоврядування не
грабуйте не нищіть
децентралізацію А давайте обмежимо тут в
парламенті що все військове ПДФО має йти
на військо
що не має йти Ні на бруківку ні на
стадіони ні на іншу Дурню на військо
визначимо це тут Верховній Раді
поставимо рамку місцевому самоврядуванню
і самі маємо виконувати те саме оця
поправка вирішить все питання і все
прошу проголосувати дякую